yes I was like you can I read it on
munching chuckles a mentally process
where people do the thing that harvest
lets but let's harvest illness avoid
babies oh yeah that's actually a really
productive way of procrastinating
although it comes with its own problems
of rationalization
so yes then you can solve it in a way
that does that those can go away to
bring up the the other individually
circuit basically you could elaborate
well I can sure run a possibility around
there senators well I've derived that
partly from my study of addiction and
also from my study of recovery from
post-traumatic stress disorder but let's
talk about addiction so there's a series
of actions that occur before you take
your cocaine some of those are local
they are the things that happened
immediately before and some of those are
distal they're farther back in the chain
of events and when you when you have a
hit of cocaine it produces a
dopaminergic burst and that feels really
good but it also makes the circuits that
were immediately active before that grow
that's what reinforcement is and then
the growth is proportionate not linearly
but it's proportionate to how long
before that event occurred the closer it
is the Hulk stronger they're going to
get but even the ones that are somewhat
distal gets some reinforcement because
you might say well what did you do
before you you found your latest fix and
the answer is well how long before well
the closer the more reward and so what
happens then is that so if you take that
person out of the normal environment you
put them into a treatment center they're
off they're a physical addiction which
is a weird thing in the case of cocaine
but like not that long a week I'll do it
two weeks for sure even heroin and
alcohol for sure if you can get them
through the seizure part without dying
and so they're done there aren't
physiologically it dependent anymore but
you let that person go and the first
thing
that happens his old friend who he's
always out doing drugs with shows up and
bang he's craving like mad and that's
because that thing is me there is not
dead at all and it's it's activated by
the cue and it's a it's a circuit it's
not it's a personality it only wants one
thing it wants cocaine it's going to
suppress any non related thoughts and
it'll use lies that's no problem
especially if lies have been reinforced
which they certainly have where are you
off to son you know you'll have a life
for that and then 10 minutes later you
have your drug and so that little lie
has just grown or maybe you think you've
tried to quit you think to hell with it
and every time 10 minutes before you
take your drug you think to hell with it
and you do that a thousand times
well believe me that to hell with it
circuit that sucker is strong and so
it's alive and it's not like it just
disappears it can't it's you it's grown
in there now you can build another
circuit to shut it down and you can help
it decompose across time by not giving
it what it wants but you're going to
have to not give it what it wants in all
of the multiple contexts that you've
already associated with the drug some of
you probably smoked and then tried to
quit smoking and what you'll see is you
get a craving when well when you have a
cup of coffee or when you're finished
dinner or when you're done having a
phone call or when you first get up in
the morning or whenever you regularly
had the drug whatever you had the drug
in relationship to even complex things
like ending a conversation will produce
acute craving and so then that can
extinguish over time if you punish it by
either punishing it or not letting it
get what it's wants but a lot you have
to build another circuit to just shut it
down and then that circuit kind of
fragile and stress can often disrupt it
so that
oh really love quitting smoking or
things like idol baby
oh sure well part of it well ibogaine is
a whole different thing because it seems
to have a direct physiological effect
but you know the the addiction has a
cognitive component it's full of
thoughts and desires and wants and you
know you may have to build up you have
may have to rebuild your whole
personality in order to to get that
thing cornered religious conversion for
example isn't really effective treatment
for alcoholism that's partly why alcohol
Alcoholics Anonymous works for the
people for whom it does work but
religious conversion which is total
personality conversion is actually one
of the few things that we know of that's
an effective treatment for alcoholism we
don't know how to induce it but although
that's not exactly true either because
the early work with Ellis V was LSD was
quite promising as a treatment for out
for alcohol addiction and there's recent
work with psilocybin showing that if you
if people have a mystical experience
when you give them psilocybin their
success rate in quitting smoking is
about 80% which is way higher than any
pharmacological intervention for smoking
has ever be so all right we should
probably call it a day so we'll see you
in a week